So the question for today if you choose to answer is I have no idea that's that's a tough question
Wow, oh my god. Oh
That is a hard question
What's your wildest dream my wildest dream oh my god
probably have a
gunfight
while
I'm falling from like, you know space just kind of falling down all over thereit's and having a gunfight pretty wicked
Just becoming a cat
We live in an ice palace on the top of a mountain in Iceland
surrounded by a
army of penguins to me Queen of England
Pull off a heist like a casino heist, that'd be that'd be really cool. My wildest dream
Why
Inside a big lawnmower
With wings
To live in a cottage with 15 dogs
Flying with the unicorn that poops rainbow
doing so much stuff like going
skydiving going at Disneyland every day
And label me. So I went to Kent I was in Canyonlands in there. There are a bunch of these candy Watchers
And then I and then one of them attacked me and then I just woke up
It was weird. Do you kind of wish that would happen through?
This why this dream is to commit his teachers because he thinks were both crazy. Yeah, is that right? Yeah
I can say that in camera
It's a boring wildest dream
torture museum
Yeah
Why?
I
Don't know. I just thought it's boring again. Oh
I just would love to like work behind the scenes cataloging
My wildest dream is to be on Broadway in New York and go to college at NYU Tisch and
I star in a Broadway show. I've always wanted to do that. It's like my wildest dream
My wildest dream is to adopt like hundreds of kids from all over the world
especially like developing worlds and
bring them to the US and raise them and give them everything that they'll ever need and send them off to college and then
just to become good people who change the world I
Think my wildest dream
Is to see my kids
Because life is so short and there's so many things that happened in life
That you don't get to live out of everything. But that thing that's one of my wildest dreams
Just to
Have a wife and live in a simple house. That's it. There's a live a simple life. That's that's it
that's my waters room, I guess right now because of the political climate just for
Us as a nation to come together to like make it impact in my community
It sounds kind of cheesy. I know it's always been like I want to shape the city of Tijuana. I
think to do that be to like
Finish a doctorate degree or something like that
I think that would be like one of my wildest dreams to be able to have that and
go back to my community and make a change to find a
40-foot beaver motorhome for $100,000
To get rich without doing anything to get a girlfriend
To get a girlfriend to retire right now
My wildest dream is to pursue my realistic dreams of opening a restaurant
Probably to own a fashion magazine one day
I gotta say my wildest dream is performing on that stage right over there to become a comedian
Mother yeah, me too. We had put the film on you have been too nervous cozies. I
Don't know that I can answer that question
I think anything that I dream of I think can be done. So it doesn't seem too wild for me
It's really unrealistic, but just sort of have like no like boundaries and just sort of be like free to do it
I want like just travel all over the place and like try new things every day
What kind of boundaries do you think you have right now that we don't work?
parents the loss money, you know, I
Don't know. I have to be happy
Would you say that you're not happy right now?
I wouldn't say that. I'm not happy. I just think to be happy all the time
Personally I just like to see all my grandchildren get home from various trips. Everybody's safe
Make something new like Steve Jobs some new technology that the world hasn't seen yet
My wildest dream. My wildest dream is to be a millionaire ruler of all of California, California is my home, you know
I don't want too big. I don't want to roll like all of America too hard presidency too much pressure
You know, I don't want to be in the spotlight
but I want to all the power I'd make a nice a nice plot of land for myself my own little city and
Then from there
I would rule all the other cities
And then this next part is you're going to say the phrase how sweet it is and then finish it
However, you'd like okay, so whenever you're ready
How sweet it is to be happy
How sweet it is to live this life today how sweet it is to be with family
How sweet it is to be loved by you
How sweet it is to live in San Diego
How sweet it is the cats exist how sweet it is to be heading off to college
How sweet it is to be with people you love
How sweet it is to be confident
How sweet it is to teach first grade how sweet it is to be artistic
How sweet it is to be happy
How sweet it is to be here with my son and enjoy
beautiful day
How sweet it is sharing fries with my wife
What's up guys, my name is Brian and I'm the owner of this channel
I'm also the person behind the camera and I thought I'd take a minute
To thank all the subscribers I gained so far and maybe ask the new year's to hit the subscribe button if you like this episode
Or if you're a fan of my channel in general, I mean a lot
Thank you